わーいーえこんにちははじめ社長です今日の動画
告知動画ですさっセンサー
いやでもおけば俺も知ってりゃピターの告知だのでつまらないと思ってる僕が3分で
マスターしたちょっと3流状況見せますエディション
その入り場がもうよかったら告知動画させてくれ
突然死の国主させるもらえますイレーザーやるから熱皆さん望みでしたら
まってまっくればやばいんだ何もわかんねーわよし見え回僕が微レ存
thirty two
ん
あ
見えるかいます間に蛍がいるだろう
これまで取ってやるとパッド出る
キュッってやるとパップれるきゅっち r 3010ちゃんと歌ってる
キュッパキュッパ頭からもパッと出る
頭サロンパッド出る著小旅行こりゃあほらほらー
パンッはぁんっポッポッ2番2
ポンツーうっ
うんああ
ああ
おっ
ん
tee
ええええええ
とおっしゃい ame
今皆様もう ust 許してくださいたまにはこっちさせてください
2点をせずすることがあります水だらもうみんな印象イレーザー見せたい形通して
投げるちゃんとホイラーに関する告知だからねそこはちゃんとはされてないよでは行き
ましょうこれも知ってる方も多いと思うんですけども
イベントのお知らせですいうフェス2010
5おいらに会えるイベントは良いを開催されますぼくだけじゃないんですけども a と
いうフェス2015というイベントがですね2015年の11月21日土曜日に開催さ
れますねと11時スタートの19時半に終了する予定でございますた以上はと寄せ
ピットという東京都の
そういう場所
1名取スピットで主催はうーむ株式会社
特別教育ボンボン tv でない用事でライブだとかゲーム実況スペシャルコラボ企画
うーむプリックらふーむオールしたハイタッチ会などまだ具体的な内容終ったらいいん
ですけどもそういうのを予定しております
何かやたば会う機会ができると思います僕とも出演いう中は基本的に風味の電波
あのほぼみんな会えますちゃんとイベントでね僕と会う機会っていうのはあんまり台と
思うのでよかったら是非来てくださいご今日はちょっと何やかや何かするんでね
チケット料金が1500円になっております
本社で先行抽選と一般販売があるんですけどもおびしゃべく選考は8月の抽出日
もうすぐ8月の17日の月曜日の23時59分までもうすぐとなっております8月の
11日までに応募してください一般販売はえっと先着順になっております2015年
10月3日土曜日
の10時からスタートでございますいう整数2015の公式サイトをご覧下さい
多分検索するつ進めていると思うんでそこからチケットをお買い求めいただけると
ありがたいでございますあんまり僕とニコガッターイベントをね
年代に1回あるかないかぐらいなのでよかったら
会いに来てください
柄でもねーなー単位でもう一つの国生なんですけども好きだな
もうすぐだと思うぞをきたぞしましたなんとなんとですね肇社長 line スタンプ
の第2弾が今日から販売開始でございます
しめちゃ第2台のでなんですけども第2弾はねゆるーくゆるーく
ちょっとキャラを書いてもらったのでもうほんとかるーく使えるスタンプリストいたん
で
始め首都スタッフ通常よかったら使ってみてください
はい以上久しぶりの告知です new face よかった僕に会いましょうっていう
話と line スタンプ外れシャツを通過てだというお話でございます質問コーナー
はたぶん来週にはたっ
いると思いますみなさんよいお盆休みよじゃあん
ええええええ